hey everybody welcome back to LED live
where we are going to expose some
darkness actually today we're probably
not gonna expose some darkness cuz we're
gonna talk about the lights right today
I've got some very important guests
today
both are my brothers and we're gonna
talk about ministry which they're all
involved in do you have a ministry find
out on this episode of LED live all
right guys I'm excited to have Tommy
back because Tommy for many of you that
don't know was actually one of the oh
jeez that started little light with us I
used to work in Hollywood with my
brother Tom here and he's got a passion
you know he's very talented with a video
camera he used to make our stuff look
amazing but there's something that that
he really felt called to do we're gonna
get into that and Brock as well Brock
being my younger brother very excited to
hear about the ministry that you've got
going on and Mikey as well for those of
you that don't know Mikey doesn't sleep
at night he actually has about 15
different ministries going on but well
we'll hear from you a little bit more so
today we want to talk about ministry
opportunities because I believe that as
the world is coming apart right
everybody needs to be involved in
ministry and a lot of people contact our
ministry and they say hey you know I
don't have a video camera and I you know
I don't know what to do but there's a
lot of things that you can do within
your means or within your local church
or just just using your passion but how
do we get to that point listen to this
verse Luke 21 verse 28 and when these
things begin to come to pass then look
up lift up your heads for your
Redemption draweth nigh mmm
so anyway what do you think this verse
is saying it's a powerful verse you know
we see the world around us falling apart
at the seams and this verse gives
incredible hope because Jesus is in
urging us to actually look up like not
to not to focus on the negativity on all
the crazy stuff that's going on that
people are depressed and struggling
these things but actually to look up
like like our redemption draws nigh
that's exciting yeah yeah when you look
around the world I mean it does appear
to be coming apart we are at 20/20 which
is like crazy I mean remember watching
movies when we were kids going like you
know seeing these futuristic 20/20 on
there and it was like always you know
people flying around in cars but we're
actually here which is amazing and you
can see the world coming apart
I mean it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to look at that no I mean I
was just hearing on NPR this last year
that there's nearly a million species
that are on the endangered they're about
to go extinct well and and you think
about that a million species and that
was just talking about animals not even
talking about the millions and millions
of plant species that we've lost yeah
you know yeah this thing is is
unraveling at an unprecedented rate I
mean you see in the news all the time
massive quantities of birds dropping off
and just out of nowhere BAM all dead or
fish washing up on the ocean I mean you
can see the effects that this sin has
had on this world and it's getting worse
and worse so tell us a little bit about
what you got going on what's it called
so we have a minister called the Gideon
rescue company and it's it's taken from
the story in the Bible about Gideon how
he was a light in a dark place you know
it's like he had he had trumpets he had
pitchers and he was outnumbered but God
used a small amount of men who are
dedicated to bring about an incredible
victory and we see this same calling and
what it is that we do because we see
natural disasters increasing all around
us and so therefore we feel that it's an
opportunity to reach people like never
before and we have this one concept
called the spiritual Golden Hour and
it's really incredible like from the
time a disaster or crisis happens and
doesn't you have to be a natural
disaster can be like a death of a friend
could be a financial crisis that
somebody's going through but from the
time that a a crisis happens the clock
starts ticking where people all of a
sudden take stock of their situation
they say well what is life really
all about like where are we headed where
are we going the big questions of life
and it's a critical moment like this is
why in the physical world we have fast
helicopters we have fast ambulances
because we we get to people quickly so
that we can hopefully get them to
definitive care quickly and it's no
different in the spiritual realm that
when a disaster happens you want to you
actually want to get to people quickly
spiritually so that you can get them to
definitive care which of course we
believe definitive care being the Word
of God right you know it's interesting
when 9/11 happened churches like
literally reversing at the seams I mean
everybody flowed into a church they saw
those buildings coming down and they're
just like whoa reevaluate life and
where's my priorities and all of a
sudden people started showing up at
churches so how did you get into this
giddy risk what do you do for a living
well by trade I work as a paramedic and
as a nurse and so different avenues they
have worked in the ER I've worked on the
helicopter but those are all great areas
to to reach people you know it's amazing
that just in the simple act of of
helping somebody through a difficult
time opens the door you know I carry
glow tracks like little tiny tracks on
Bible topics and you know somebody will
be struggling doesn't even matter what
it is that they're struggling with if
the time in the appropriate situation
arises I can hand them a glow track and
they're just like so thankful they're
just like oh man thank you so much you
know or even just praying with somebody
so back to praying with somebody it
makes all the difference in the world
yeah when you when you when you've got a
in a rescue vehicle like a paramedic
ambulance or something like this right
you have a captive audience yeah they're
they're yours work that half hour ride
or whatever you got so you know so do
you pray with patience or what yeah yeah
absolutely it's it's really amazing
we're working down the ER they actually
it's a it's a Christian hospital so they
actually promote ministry they actually
promote praying with people so that's
that's really neat to have on that
aspect you know I have that kind of
backup is that they like to see that I I
heard something actually that was really
interesting that when somebody is ill or
has a terminal illness or a sickness or
something that if they exude
thankfulness or compassion was it
gratitude gratitude
that it actually totally increases your
ability to heal yeah yeah they've done
scientific studies on on gratitude and
have proven that patients who are more
grateful recover faster have faster
healing times so you know it isn't great
it isn't just the work that you're doing
you know patching somebody if they're if
they're bleeding or whatever like that
but there's actually like a like a
spiritual component that really helps
heal somebody as well and obviously that
ties into what Gideon Rescue does right
right and that's the point is that most
ailments even physical ailments stem
from a spiritual foundation and it's
really fascinating people you know
that's at the heart of what people
really struggle with usually is a
spiritual ailment and Jesus recognized
this you know he would physically heal
someone for the purpose of spiritually
reaching someone you know he was
teaching he was preaching he was healing
it was those three combinations that
opened the door in fact he did most most
of his healing more than he did
preaching you know like a few instances
where we see his sermons and his
parables but the majority of his work
was actually a medical missionary you
actually see that as one of his first
lines of attack rather than just like
hey do you know what the Bible says
about this you know I mean like he was
actually just helping people and you
know making them eased in a
discomforting world so so tell me a
little bit about getting a risk Gideon
rescue like what are some of the
activities that your ministry has done
well we've been blessed to respond to
all sorts of disasters and God has
blessed us with incredible resources we
are the least the least the fewest of
the few but in the same fashion that God
used less than 1% of Gideon's original
fighting force God has also blessed us
in that same capacity with untold
resources to accomplish the mission I
mean he's given us planes that we don't
own that we don't maintain that we don't
pay for I mean these are not just simple
planes these are multi-million dollar
planes you know recent acquisition was a
five million dollar aircraft you know we
don't own it we don't pay for it but you
know God has seen fit to give it to us
to use whenever we need to it's on call
ready to go you know personal get in
rescue pilot check you know so we
wouldn't have time to tell all the
credible miracle stories that God is
doing but you also we have a boat with
rescue boat that
our church stepped out in faith to
purchase which this is really exciting
it's it's a it's a one of the best tools
in the water environments for flood
rescue and things and so these are all
tools they open doors like when you show
up to a disaster scene and you have
physical tools to help people then men
like doors just open up like you
wouldn't believe
but you know glow tracks like literature
the messages that we have from the Bible
are one of our greatest tools that we
found that open up doors I mean it's
incredible we've been on the scene we're
at hurricane durian this last fall and
people were literally turning down food
and water saying no I want the book in
your hand no I want the tract in your
hand I mean this is how hungry people
are I mean they've been through a lot
they've suffered a lot but then again
where's that foundation you know it's
like you can you can go weeks without
food days without water
you know minutes without air but you
can't live a moment without hope right
so it's like what do you give people
like what do they need they need hope
and that's something simple anybody can
do nobody has to be a preacher you know
and there might be somebody who's just
really introverted and they just man I
just cannot talk to somebody about
spiritual things if they bought a pack
of those and I've heard stories where
somebody laid it on a trash can at a gas
station and they find out like months
later somebody calls them up because
they left the number in there and like
just a man this I found this on the edge
of the trash can right the right time
like you'd have no idea you could change
somebody's entire world you know if you
just left that one little thing it's
something means you can do you know
everybody can do it
and that's incredible like when we were
there and this is what was heartbreaking
so we had thousands of people pouring
through our area through our hands to
say and we didn't have enough hands mmm
we didn't have enough literature like we
all you work there to do was to pray
with somebody or to offer them a glow
track I mean we could have made such an
incredible impact and we had four guys
you almost need like a tactical gear
dragon you know it's like yeah like 15
pockets on it right all the glue tracks
you know like when we work with other
rescue teams and ministries and stuff
yeah absolutely I mean we team up with
whoever was one day to team up I had a
question
because I seen this meme one time on the
internet it really just kind of bothered
me it was like it's from an atheist and
he posted it and it showed a circus show
to Christians holding hands in a circle
praying and it said this is how
Christians respond to like natural
disasters and stuff and I was just like
are you kidding me like I had to respond
because I looked up like who are the
first responders who are hospitals like
all these things are run by Christians
right people who care people whose lives
have been transformed by Jesus care
about other people do you find that the
majority of rescue work like you do are
run by Christians or there is a huge
number I mean you know you look at like
World Vision they were there in the
Bahamas they had a helicopter and some
other things that they were running and
so there's very physical aspects that
these ministries do I mean we show up
with a physical boat you know the pull
people from the water we didn't use it
in that particular rescue response but
that's the point is that when you
physically reach somebody you then have
an avenue to spiritually minister so
yeah I mean I would say there's a huge
number of Christian organizations and
groups that give of their time their
talent in an effort to physically reach
people yeah but what we see less and
less of and and this is where we we feel
that this is the gap is that not a lot
of groups are really focusing on the
spiritual aspect especially in the
critical phases you know later on things
stabilize you know down the road then
maybe you know churches will come
together and kind of try to do some
things but in the acute phase that's
when it's most important yeah there's
like a window of opportunity because
people once they get back on their feet
they kind of just forget like I mean
I've been in some crazy incidences where
I almost like drown and everything and
it ain't like for days that for as I
could have died and now it's just like I
was a long time ago I barely remember it
but during that little window of
opportunity you can really reach
somebody and you might miss that
opportunity if you don't take advantage
of it right and that's and that's
exactly what we see you know I mean we
had a report of a guy who showed up at
the airport there we were at in the
Bahamas and he dropped his whole family
off and then after he dropped his day
off he pulled out a gun and shot himself
mm you know and and that is I mean has
he lost everything is there no hope no
hope so it's like so in that instance
like is food important for that family
absolutely is water important for the
family absolutely is pulling those
people from the flood important
absolutely
but there's a lot of teams that do those
things those physical things but then
there's not a lot of teams that will
offer hope yeah and that's the most
important piece of the entire my giving
hope to that person where he's still
alive with his family is very important
more important you know this ministry
was basically born in Paradise
California where all the fires were and
it's really been interesting because
that's where I grew up you know I went
and visited the the town this last year
and there's just nothing left of it and
and that that was the one thing is it's
like people were leaving that situation
with just no hope everything is gone
everything is burnt I don't wanna start
over they're old you know and it's like
you know what a discouraging thing but
when you have this other thing to look
forward to like you're just like wow
this this this literally isn't the end I
mean this can make a lot of sense yeah
and then that person goes and shares
it's like wildfire right yeah no pun
intended but yeah like when you Sharon
change somebody's life they get a fire
within them and they want to share and
that's just crazy to see just that's
right
that's right so Brock what kind of
people do you work with I mean what you
know Gideon rescue what what are you
like teaming up with are you guys all
like medical personnel are you guys all
like super trained in whitewater rescue
and no there's a couple of us that have
some specialized skills and training you
know paramedic nurse EMT but beyond that
I mean we've got we've got a guy that
works on our team he's like a mortgage
broker you know that's what he does like
he just sells houses but he's all
excited about this this ministry got
another guy that used to work in
warehouse he worked for like Dollar
General Dollar Tree a camera which one
and he got excited about it and he his
he's a new convert to Christianity and
so he's been really excited about
literature and so he'll go to like a
truck stop
he'll be handin like you know semi
truckers just a teacher you know so so
when he found out about our ministry and
the opportunity to go and do that in a
disaster scene he was just like oh I'm
in you know he has no skills whatsoever
you know like he's even afraid of water
like he doesn't like water yeah so once
he once they got in there and
experienced what this was like then they
keep coming back with you yeah yeah I
mean you know it's a small group like I
said most of the time our responses are
like three four guys at the most we
don't have huge teams you know it would
be nice to have a bigger team but we
just haven't had that opportunity to
have right right a big if somebody
wanted to join your team
what would you tell them like if
somebody was watching yeah absolutely
man I mean visit our website we got a
way that you can go to you know getting
a rescue or you can you type in a little
contact submission form there and then
we just we take it case by case we send
you information you know and then it's
it's really a we have no requirements as
far as to join except to realize what it
is that you're getting into you know
like these are high-octane environments
this is a stressful environment and so
the thing that we found to bring the
most success is you have to have a solid
relationship with God and if your
relationship with God is is solid then
you can then serve in some of these
crazy environments and be a light and a
witness right and so that's where the
only requirement we put on people but
it's not something we can measure
location matter I mean you guys do you
go to other places all over all over the
United States internationally wherever
the Lord will take us I mean so far he's
given us some aircraft here in the US so
we can kind of reach anywhere in the US
right yeah you live in California and if
there's a disaster like in Tennessee you
could call somebody in Georgia and they
can meet up with your son well yeah I
mean and in this what's so cool is that
because we do this all in faith and we
don't have the game plan or the battle
plan laid out just like Gideon it's like
God then it's like as you step forward
in faith like you know what I'm gonna do
this then God starts opening up the
doors like he clear schedules he finds
transportation I mean all these things
come together even though we don't have
an extensive network to do this like I
can't tell somebody who's wanted to join
be like yeah I'm gonna fly you from
California to where we're at yeah in the
disaster we don't have that capability
per se but God has the capability and
he's never disappointed us so where if
people set forward and faith man the
Lord hooks it up and when that disaster
happens you somehow it works out and
everybody gets to the location and you
guys are able to be really effective
boots on the ground yeah exactly
that's awesome Mike he's got a little
ministry tell me a little bit about your
ministry so I have a youtube channel
called truth to the youth and
I have a passion to reach the youth the
younger generation when my parents
raised me up in church so I was there
every week and I just when I got to age
I accepted Christ and as a young kid I
wasn't going to these youth groups and I
was on fire but then when I reached age
12 and 13 I started having these real
skeptical tough questions and so I'd ask
pastors and and I know I look back on I
really hammered him I was kind of like
because I really had these skeptical
questions and I would get it would end
up being where the pastor whoever I was
talking to would just be like there's
some things I just won't know till we
get to heaven and it's just like really
you know added more skepticism to my
life so I started seeking truth in other
areas I was like you know how come we
can't play with a Ouija board and and
contact spirits from the other side that
might have information for us nobody
told me this is why you shouldn't do it
I have the answer it's in the Bible you
know so my desire is to seek answers for
really tough questions for skeptical
mindsets of the youth of this day and
age a truth to the youth and if I don't
have the answer then my mission is to
search it out I love to be stumped
because it makes me dig deeper but I
have a lot of interaction online on
social media with atheist and agnostics
I get a lot of debates yes I'm just kind
of a natural debater and you know I
often respond to our comments on this
YouTube channel that are the haters and
I try to give them you know logical
explanations for what we believe in
stuff and you know what's awesome about
what he does cuz III - I read the
comments and I often see you responding
to people and a lot of times even if
they did it dislike this topic I mean a
real negative like you guys are crazy
you know and usually you would maybe
skip over those comments because you're
like okay this person is not really
seeking truth but I've seen my key a lot
engage with these people go back and
forth Hanan some truth and then it's
like all of a sudden these people are
like friends with you down the road and
like accepting of the truth which they
never would have if you didn't spend the
time to sit there and communicate with
them that's right man I've had I've had
dialogues that last days on
Media and finally like a Christian
friend of mine will literally private
message me and be like dude stop casting
her pearls among swine dust her feet off
and I'm like no man if somebody would
have done that to me where would I be
right now right I was I was like you
know telling Christians that they were
dumb for believing this stuff and and I
was going down the road of witchcraft
and all this stuff and if it was not for
people continuing to pursue me you know
my cousin was the one that said man you
just read the Bible just give it a
chance man like it's changed my life and
I've talked with some of these people
over a long periods of time sometimes it
takes a long time but eventually when
they get to a point in their life
something happens some devastating even
if it's just like a breakup a heartbreak
those people come to me hey hit me up in
a private message in me light and their
hearts just open in a different way
but it's because like you said I was
willing to sit there and talk with them
and keep talking so I like making videos
tough topics doctrinal things and
prophecy and things like that
I don't spend a lot of time on that
aspect because I work here and I love
doing the videos here but a lot of my
ministry is just on social media yeah
and I can just communicating with people
I mean dude everybody has social media
that is the one ministry that we don't
even realize it is a ministry I mean you
know get it get involved and answer some
questions especially if you're a
Christian and you guys understand
certain biblical truths I mean there's a
lot of people out there that are
generally like unaware of some of these
simple basic concepts and it can be as
simple as just you know engage with them
and and and sit and chat with people did
I have I have so many testimonies I'm
always like sharing with Scottie cuz I
just feel like I can connect with him
show him and he'll get excited the same
way and I'll be like look dude this guy
like made this video and he was talking
about this topic and I you know I showed
him hey read these verses and now all of
a sudden he sees like the truth about
this topic and now like he changed this
whole ministry to to sharing this truth
that we understand you know ya see that
kind of stuff all the time and all of a
sudden it's just literally like one
person at a time and one person at a
time one percent time that's how Jesus
worked I mean when I when I think of
Jesus's minutes
he was often boots on the ground one on
one you know I mean he did give big
presentations to big amounts of people
but that was that there's a few examples
of that as opposed to how many times he
went to someone's house or he just
communicated with him so you know where
people think like I can't be I don't
have a big ministry I don't have I don't
know I'm not that ministry frontman yeah
but you got friends you got family
members that don't know about God you
got you got you know people within your
short distance easy that you can just
start sharing with them and Christ met a
guy I don't know where you're going with
that but I just met a guy he actually
left a comment on our video and he said
hey check out my video link and you know
sometimes we just could ignore that type
of thing but I like to let check it out
so I looked and this guy he's from
Maryland he's a veteran it wasn't raised
in a Christian home he his eyes were
open to the signs of the times and and
he accepted Christ and he's like man all
my family are non-believers he's got an
older brother younger sister and and his
parents even so he made a video and in
the video he tried to put all the
evidences that prove the Bible logical
stuff that people want to know you know
these people think we believe in
fairytales but there's evidence
historical archaeological evidence and
that's what he did he started out
archaeological evidence for stuff like
Sodom and Gomorrah finding sulfur balls
and it looks like in the in the
mountains there's actually man-made
places where people used to live and now
it's just like wasteland and then he'd
show signs of the times and say look the
Bible predicted we'd see Wars rumors of
wars natural disasters famines all this
stuff and he's the whole video was just
his heart being poured out trying to
reach his family look I'm not crazy
I have reasons to believe this stuff
God's changed my life you know I used to
drink and smoke and party and all this
stuff God's changed my life I'm not that
person anymore and he's just pouring his
heart out and that's something anybody
can do you know make it and he put it on
YouTube right didn't reach his parents
but his YouTube channels blowing up
yeah and other people are seeing it yes
so so his initial intent was to reach
his family making little videos and I
think I think I remember seeing a couple
of these videos all it was
smashing together other videos right
from other people it wasn't even stuff
he created he's literally just like like
look at this video and watch this so
everyone has YouTube you guys all have
YouTube you can literally make a
playlist or even better yet you can just
copy that URL and say hey man I saw this
really cool video share stuff with
people that's a ministry in and of
itself one thing everybody has is a
testimony if you just get your phone you
might not have great equipment put a
phone on a tripod sit down and just
share your story and upload it to
YouTube and sit back and don't do
anything to it if you just do that
you're at least putting it out there you
have no clue who might stumble upon that
video and then you make it to heaven one
day and a thousand years go by you you
man I ran across your video you should
know what God did in your life and I
watched it and I poured my heart out to
God when I accepted Christ and this
person all they did was made a video and
even if it only reaches one person right
that's right it's worth it you st. you
gave that you helped that person to see
the light and receive eternal life
that's worth it man if you were speaking
to a million people and only one person
accepted it it's worth it
we have that same perspective I can't
tell you we have so many stories of like
just a one-on-one encounter you know
where we've been you know in a natural
disaster scene and we tell people all
that all the time if God would pull out
all the stops and put us on planes and
send us halfway across the globe if it
was just to reach you in this moment in
time so that we could share with you
hope and encouragement from God's Word
know then it would be worth it and man
when people see that they're just
they're blown away because it's like God
takes a personal interest in me that
much that he cares about me and and they
want to know more yeah I love this
there's a POW for illustration I use it
all the time
where a kid was walking on the beach and
there's all these starfish washed up on
the sand and he's going he's picking him
up and throwing him out there this old
man sees him he's watched him take him
one at time I throw him out there he's
like you know you can't save him all
he's like but for the ones I save it's
worth it you know to them it's worth it
that one gets to live that's right
that's right I tell these people you
like if you're interested because I
don't want to give some a book away I
have a lot of stuff I've collected on a
shelf of material that I like and I
don't want to
give us somebody who's gonna throw it
away but when people are really
interested I'm like if you want these
books I'll send it to you free like
there's no strings attached when I give
them to you yeah so truth to the youth
dot-com no just go on YouTube and type
truth the number two tha truth to the
youth and you can find some of my videos
and if you just hit me up on myspace
Mikey Jenny you know if you know
somebody I mean my my catch me on
Facebook and yeah man my messenger is
just full of people like literally that
I'm just talking back and forth with it
are asking me to pray for them for
different things and what if what do you
understand about this you know I was
sometimes I'll just like be talking to
somebody and then there's no interaction
a weeks later they're like hey I heard
this what do you think about this you
know and that's that's cool it's awesome
all right Thomas I want to hear about
you tell me a little bit about some of
your ministry ventures by the way this
is the man who started Tommy's tonic if
many of you have tried this we've had
Tommy's tonic on our show before and
just talked about it it's a natural
remedy tell us a little bit about it how
did you get involved in this well was
just a formula that I came across
actually from dr. Schultz and I started
making it myself sharing it with my
friends and family and it just quickly
became a a really just powerful little
means of helping someone you know just a
thing as simple as a cold or a flu sore
throat it worked so well for me started
giving it out to to everyone around me
and working for them and then finally
got around to making a website and
getting a label created where people
come in to you and be like hey give me
that little concoction yeah all the time
I mean literally he was making batches
and then you just walk around with
bottles it's like hey you sick of this
what's in Tommy's tonics yeah so I juice
garlic ginger habanero pepper
which is a Cayenne light onion and
horseradish and then that's preserved in
Bragg rava cider vinegar so lean if my
nose has stopped up and I put it in
before I even swallow it it's just oh
yeah that's the horseradish yeah tommy's
tonic is is you know really one of those
products that that I think when you get
sick there's there's not a lot of things
that actually make you well and people
swear by this stuff I mean you're
selling the stuff around the world yeah
I mean what the what I've learned with
it is just the power of food you know I
mean look at these things God has given
us garlic ginger and onions and
horseradish root you know and some
cayenne pepper and I mean it's it's it's
incredible to me that you can take just
some very simple ingredients and make
something that really does work that's
what I hear from so many people man it
really works and I mean it's not me you
know it's it's ya you God made this
these ingredients that that are just put
together from from what yeah God's given
us out of the garden yeah my cousins my
in-laws my household we use it yeah it
started out just me getting a bottle
here and Wow then owed my wife you want
to try it and then her giving it to her
mom and it just sprays everybody's like
the same words don't yeah so would you
say you kind of have like a health
ministry
I think Health's always been a passion
for sure I mean you know it's meeting
people where they're at and meeting
people's needs I mean I love that I have
something always that I can you know if
I see somebody who's suffering I can
just give it to him you know typically
if someone's sick I mean I'm not selling
it to him you know I just say hey try
the soup Awards who works for you yeah
he's like he's like he's like a vegan
drug dealer but they keep coming back
because it works yeah I keep coming back
his works and it's just been that little
side you know thing to to do and and
help people with food has always been a
passion of mine so that's why you know I
love the Hippocrates quote you know food
be thy medicine medicine be thy food you
know that whole concept of yeah powerful
food ingredients and and and trying to
come up with really nutrient-dense no
side effects
yeah no side effects I remember in is
the world is obsessed with these kind of
like food alternatives now it's like
we've been eatin terrible diets for
years right and all of a sudden now it's
like you see these these documentaries
starting to come out you know
forks over knives or anything
yeah game-changer any of these that that
all of a sudden its is simple we tried
it our way for a while there's simple
little things that you can do that
actually make you healthy well and
that's what I love about it though it
when comes to health because really what
God is showing us in terms of health
it's not complex it's simple but the
results are profound you know and that's
what's powerful in for the gospel right
the gospel is not it's not this complex
you have to really jump through all
these hoops to be saved it's simple I
believe on the Lord Jesus Christ should
be saying that's right but but yeah it's
profound in its effect that's right
that's right so tell me a little bit
about what's this picture they're seeing
right here this is see five years ago I
answered a call to go to Casa Bella Utah
and it's a boarding Academy situated on
a 300 acre farm and farming also has
been a little passion of mine you know
from when we were in paradise and meetin
Lynn Hogan and learning all his
gardening methods and everything so when
I got to the school I really just fell
in love with the farm and have
progressed from the classroom more and
more on with the farm and predominantly
work on the farm now so that's just been
something that his has has just been a
passion of mine for sure farming and
it's an amazing place to farm you know
yeah I mean just look at this it's
absolutely beautiful I mean it looks
like something out of a picture because
when you when you come into Castle
Valley it's like you're in desert desert
desert desert and all of a sudden you
drop over the hill into this oasis you
see all this greenery in the blue skies
and the Red Rocks it's really actually
this this stunningly beautiful place
yeah it's a desert oasis and you know
with our food crisis situation
the planet today you know with more and
more as the farms get larger and we hear
about these mergers happening in between
you know biotech companies and drug
companies and chemical companies and
yeah you know trying to just GMO food
everything over our entire food supply
do do you bile or do you get a lot of
like heirloom stuff yeah so we grow a
lot of heirloom is there a so this might
be kind of stuff is there risk of your
gardening getting contaminated by GMO
stuff it's actually a beautiful thing
about where we're at were situated you
know in the middle of the desert so
there's so much space around us we could
actually grow corn you know for seed and
not have it contaminated where that's
really hard to do in a lot of places
because corn pollen will travel you know
long distances so yeah it's it's an it's
a good spot for it I mean there's
definitely challenges to the environment
where we're we're we're farming I'm just
drying but like that's everywhere you
know I mean you it's very few places
that are completely ideal you know so
yeah you know most of our customers are
really local so our foods not going that
far I mean we're driving it maybe 20
miles away you know kind of thing so you
guys are growing food and you're taking
it to what health food stores
restaurants what are you doing Moab is
is 17 miles from us town of Moab and
there's a little market there a moon
flower market by as most of our produce
from us and then restaurants we sell a
lot too the town is predominantly hotels
and restaurants so and that's a means
for the school to support itself it's a
self-supporting
boarding Academy and the students that
come there learn agriculture is is one
of the first you know so you ABCs of
Education at this school and so that's
what the kids they're learning they they
come there and they're they're told you
know you can't have your phone can't
have you know you have limited access to
a computer and at first they're like no
and I think there's a lot of students
that don't come just because of that
aspect but once they get there and they
real
you know huh I'm actually fine without
my phone yeah a little detox right right
one thing I want to say you know this is
you have a mystery everybody well what I
think is cool is like everybody's so
individual and unique like he loves
gardening I tried it I hated it you know
that weeding and everything but he has a
passion for you have a passion for
getting on helicopters and saving people
not everybody can do that right yeah I
mean I I don't think I can stomach half
of the stories that he's told about like
a paramedic what they deal with
especially the flight paramedics when
you're on a helicopter crew you're
picking up the worst of the worst of the
worst I mean you've had to like walk
down freeways and look for limbs that
have come off of people before and so
like not everyone can do that I mean I
would I would literally be sick to my
you know stomach and probably couldn't
perform under those circumstances we're
talking about off-camera like that even
old ladies and stuff could knit hats for
any given to people you know everybody
can do something man yeah there is
literally a ministry opportunity
anywhere you are I mean Tommy you have a
you have a passion for for food as well
like you mentioned so talk about some of
these products that you're making like
what is this we're in an effort to have
zero waste on the farm we got on the
freeze dryer donated to us actually a
couple of them and we've started to
freeze-dry everything we have an
abundance of so you know like we had
tons of melons that you know we just
Muraki sell all these before they go bad
so we start freeze drying them and you
can freeze dry things that you can't
normally dehydrate like we have an
asparagus a one-acre asparagus plot and
when it's pumping I mean it's like we
got asparagus coming out our ears so
we're freezing as much as we can and you
can just fill freezers and then once you
know you come into wintertime you got
one more time you can start running
stuff through the through the freeze
dryer and you know you can't dehydrate
asparagus but you can freeze dry you
can't dehydrate zucchini but you can
freeze dry it yeah he makes freeze-dried
kale salad I mean we're talking with the
cranberries and the nuts and the and the
scales like salad dressing when you're
eating it it's like you're eating a
whole kale salad but it's like this
yummy
yeah I mean his kids were walking around
the other day with with this little bag
of freeze dried grapes yeah and I was
like hey let me let me see that let me
then give me one of those you know and I
tried one it was literally like a piece
of candy I mean if you have a sweet
tooth this was like literally like
eating eating like cotton candy or
something I mean that's what it tasted
like now I've heard about this legendary
carrot hot dog he takes these to the
farmers market and and literally sells
out of these things so talk a little bit
about this so yeah it came out of uh
just a conversation I was having with a
friend of mine she had a vegan
restaurant in California and she said
her best-selling menu item was a carrot
hot dog and I instantly thought like
envision myself at a vegan restaurant
seeing that on a menu it'd be the last
thing the carrot in a bun yeah yeah not
happening yeah so the next year she kept
talking about it so how make you one you
know so she made me wanted I mean I just
had like a paradigm shift yeah and I was
completely blown away and so I came home
just started experimenting and looking
up different recipes and kind of came up
with our own little recipe for it
basically you're steaming a carrot down
and marinating it for 24-48 hours in a
marinade that makes it end up tasting
like a hot dog you know and then you put
that in a nice homemade bun with you
know homemade sauerkraut and we've been
making a cashew cauliflower Mayo a
tumeric mustard and heirloom tomato
ketchup Wow
so we're making all the mouth is
watering it's like a full artesian you
know like homemade food item in it so
yeah you're taking one of the worst
American foods
and I just yeah I was like this is this
and start a ministry event like this and
so wait you've taken this to farm
markets yes we take it to farmers market
we have a carrot little hot dog cart in
Moab happens on Tuesdays we just ended
we went all the way to the to the lat to
the Tuesday just before Christmas was
our last market we shut down and then
we'll open back up into March so what
kind of people are lining up at your
booth here these like hippies you know
he's like so types I mean he ran all the
evening like I had you guys come by the
market and they were like yeah we'll try
one of your hot dogs you know okay so
like anything is that I'm like what do
you want on it he's like whatever you
think is good you know yeah I put
everything you know they turned around
they yeah we'll take another one you
know I know we're taking these two guys
ate four of them and at the NDC's he's
like man you know hot dogs you know on
the street and you would never put you
know ketchup on a hot dog it's just
mustard but that was really good you
know and and they were just blown away
and that's the response a lot of people
are like wow how'd you make it taste
like a hot dog you know and and then
we've just recently gotten a couple of
these corn dog waffle irons and been
making carrot corn dogs as well so we've
got hot dogs and corn dogs so we use
this as a means to help pay for the
school to go on certain trips like the
school we're going as a school all the
students most of the faculty to an
agriculture conference and we'll set up
this cart at this conference in and
we'll sell we're gonna make 700 hotdogs
for this for this event and that'll have
that help helps to pay for our event and
it gives the students opportunity to you
know serve at a at a food cart you know
and learn that whole process and
business enterprise yeah Bennis business
enterprise like we're looking at
building a trailer actually and going
more full-time with it as well you know
to go outside of like baseball stadiums
and stuff man right yeah that would be
the true test I mean like people that
are like they want their ballpark dog
you know and
if you can see that paradigm shift yeah
like I was talking about like people
like I don't know just try it yeah
that's right the like whoa yeah first
little sample stream you know everybody
is we're kind of getting more
health-conscious this kids really take
off man I mean you might have I just got
a little paper in the mail yesterday
that said the Hardee's now has a
plant-based thing so a lot of people are
I mean we got Burger King and Hardee's
and right KFC like that impossible
Burger has taken over the world you know
I mean there there's certain people
vegetarian people that have had
conversations with that don't like the
impossible burger because it tastes like
a real yeah Wow that's cool yeah it's
very cool so you know I mean this is
somebody who's taken a passion I like
cooking and you know what everybody
likes hot dogs so I'm gonna figure out
how to like you know make this thing
healthy and and then all of a sudden
taking it to farmers markets I've had
conversations with you people start
asking questions why you into this now
you got this opportunity to talk to
people that you didn't just walk in the
room and be like hey you should start
being eating more healthy you know what
I mean like that wasn't the first thing
it's just like I love the idea of making
healthy food taste good yeah because
that's that's that's the real reason why
I think most people don't want to be
healthy they don't know what yeah I
don't want to eat that cuz they feel
like they're giving up on something you
know it's like the taste buds have been
so used to some of the other sugars and
high in you know eating that they don't
they don't feel like it's gonna be
satisfying okay when you when you taste
and see man it's good in a really good
reason to be healthy and take care about
it is this is our temple man we yeah we
got to live with his body and the longer
we stay alive and healthy the longer
that we can you know bring people into
the kingdom I worked at a hospital
obvious valet I wouldn't like it
nurse or anything but I would see people
some people in their 70s get out with a
walker and they can barely move and then
I'd see somebody else jump out and he's
like how would you think oh I'm like I
don't know he's like I'm 90 I'm like
whoa what so I mean you can see like wow
we what we do what our health can really
and on that you know and health is no
you know seeing working with patients in
the hospital or in the ambulance or the
helicopter when you lose health you lose
everything you know it's like nothing
else matters but what what would
somebody do to gain back their health
and most often it's anything yeah yeah
yeah it's actually one of the top things
that people talk about when they're
dying there's actually a book that was
written where a nurse she kept having
people dying around her and they kept
talking about these like ten very common
things and you know when you lose your
health it makes you really start to
think about what's really important in
life like you don't care about that BMW
you don't care about that house you know
people start really prioritizing what
was my life really supposed to be about
and so yeah health is you don't want to
wait too late because many of your
damage is already being done that's
right that's right awesome so you
mentioned earlier this little article
that talked about NPR 1 million animal
and plant species are at the risk of
extinction I mean that's that's what the
world is is is coming to I mean they
they say there's about 8 million plant
and animal species on on the world but 1
million that's 1/8 of the the life on
the planet is literally in danger of
extinction right now that's that's where
we're at right now we're seeing
incredible stressors on the planet all
over you know it doesn't it's not just
related to the animal and plant kingdom
I mean you know we see it in the
political realm you know in this in
society around us in general I mean it
this world is literally bursting at the
seams with problems yeah some of the
signs are the the love of many growing
cold yeah you see people like
videotaping people drowning and video
taking fights and they're not even
trying to help the wars are just going
crazy natural disasters I mean it if you
look at like a chart of earthquakes and
stuff it's just up up up above I mean
more intense more frequent I I have that
try here this is actually this is
actually website called our world and
data and they track data across the
world for natural disasters and and they
break it down like you look at you can
look at just tsunamis you can look at
just earthquakes you can look
just fires you can break it all down but
this act this particular chart here is
all natural disasters what's incredible
and undeniable about a science and you
can see it is that you know 1900 which
we go back and we remember from history
like the great San Francisco earthquake
I mean huge you know destroy the whole
city and a lot of people died in that
earthquake but but you know you kind of
had disasters that were a common
fluctuating theme most years and it was
pretty steady 1900s until all of a
sudden you hit like the 1980s and once
you hit the 1980s it's like the chart
just skyrockets and like we're talking
an incredible climb in the amount of
disasters frequency intensity damage
that they're causing and and then even
into the mid-2000s and we kind of seemed
like to have this little lull right now
like 2010 was kind of like a peak where
we saw an incredible amount of heavy
hitting disasters you know that you know
we saw Katrina before that we saw Haiti
we saw the Fukushima you know tsunami if
you guys ever watched footage of that
it's nuts you know like little cars
driving on the road and this huge tidal
wave just like wiping them out and the
fires and kill fires in California you
know it's unprecedent seems like every
year we keep coming up against
challenges that are something that we
have never before seen like a bruit to
the hurricane Andorian in the Bahamas
you know the Islanders they're the
locals were telling us you know we've
seen category 5 storms and a category 5
storm is is the story is destructive I
mean you're talking about 200 miles an
hour sustained winds and yeah and and
yeah so 2 mile sustained winds but they
said that's not what was so destructive
about the storm they said what was crazy
was that inside that storm they saw
multiple large tornadoes coming down out
of the storm and touching down on the
ground at the same time we've never seen
that before we've never seen tornadoes
inside a hurricane they're causing
damage like that yeah and every time you
see an article it's always like the
biggest flood in Texas history it's
always like the biggest the biggest the
biggest yeah yes it's no longer it's no
longer like you know news anymore it's
just commonplace or another school
shooting oh somebody just yesterday
Sunday walked into the church and opened
fire and then guys in the church were
worth armed and they opened fire and
they killed the gunman I mean see the
world we live in today you can die going
to church
like I've been to lots of churches where
there's a police officer that sits
outside in fact around here they have
police officers that sit outside of the
churches and one time I walked over to
the officer and I was just like you know
hey you gonna come in here like what'd
he do and he said though he says we're
actually protecting the churches just in
case something goes down you know and
it's like whoa that's crazy
that's the world we live in moving dying
yeah I get shot
Walmart parking lot yeah yeah so to get
involved in ministry we know the end of
the world is right around the corner
check out this verse revelation 14 verse
8 said and there followed another angel
saying Babylon is fallen is fallen that
great city because she's made all
nations drink of the wine of the wrath
of her fornication so this is where
we're at this is a message for the end
of the world saying listen this systems
of the world are breaking down right so
this is the second angels message right
there's three of them and this is the
second angels message basically
declaring that the world systems and
everything connected with it are failing
and we're seeing that like if you look
at politics people will agree across the
board doesn't matter what aisle of the
party that you sit on we agree that
politics are failing bro and it's not
just the United States it's all around
the world I mean France incredible
upheaval in their political system right
now because they can't maintain their
course oh yeah yeah Korea China Hong
Kong and the protests and everything
okay so I mean incredible failure of
systems and doesn't matter whether
you're communist or democratic or
Republican I mean we're seeing these
things fail and so people are
recognizing we're in a very incredible
time period you know and it's not just
not just that but I mean like you said
the love of many growing cold I mean
Society is breaking down and those are
those norms that used to be able to
protect us we can't count on those
enables so what are we supposed to be
doing right now
I mean we're people of God we're we're
his children what we supposed to be
doing just hunkering down which we run
to the hills' like what what's what what
do you think like we all need to be
doing right now I think it's the same as
it was in the very beginning I mean you
look in in Genesis chapter 2 where it
says the Lord placed man in a garden
to teach him about his character and he
gave him two tasks he said I mean the
Bible says to address and to keep but
really if you look at the translation of
those two words it's to serve and
preserve mmm we were called to serve and
preserve mmm serve and preserve serve
and preserve preserve preserve you know
I mean that's that's our calling yeah I
mean you look at what Jesus did when he
came here yeah wash people's feet serve
and preserve I came to give life and to
give it more abundantly
amen you know it's a life of service is
is where we're gonna find our greatest
joy and you know what's interesting here
is really four unique ministries you've
got a book ministry you've got a rescue
ministry we've got a media ministry
you've got a gardening ministry but yet
we're all really seriously on the same
yeah we're all in the same task that's
to preserve life to give them hope to
give them healing I mean that's
literally what we're doing what it
really you know in connection with
Revelation 14 8 you know this really
continues on because you you see that
that revelation continues with this
theme to come out of her my people so
not always Babylon fallen but the next
step is then to disconnect like you've
got to disconnect from the world in the
system's because it's not sustainable if
we if we remain plugged into Babylon and
her systems in any way shape form or
fashion it's gonna take us down and so
God's God's advice to us and this time
is you've got to disconnect unplug you
know get out of that system get on the
ark yeah my other city don't even look
back you know it's always been that way
right and so I love that you know like
what you guys do here with a little
light it's like that's that call it's
like disconnect like realize that this
stuff has a profound effect on us and
the time is now to unplug like you know
make sure you clear it up it's just to
distract you so much that you're wasting
all this precious time to reach this
harvest that we're talking about like
people are reaching a state of
hopelessness because everything's
failing perfect time to reach out and
share the gospel you're just sitting
there staying at a TV for hours I mean
think of all the people you could have
witnessed too right opportunity and
that's what actually excites me the most
is that you know
where God has led us at this point it's
like man there are unprecedented
opportunities in the face of
unprecedented challenges our
unprecedented opportunities and I would
say the opportunities are even greater
because the challenges are so large you
know it's like David I love the story of
David Goliath right it's like everybody
else is looking at the scene in the
situation they see it a giant who is is
you know it's impossible you know
there's no way that they're gonna be
able to take on this giant in their own
strength and yet David looks a situation
he's like you know is there not a cause
yeah like he's David saw opportunity
where everybody else saw challenge David
said no this is an opportunity for God
you know to gain the credit that's right
that's right Jonathan and his
armor-bearer you know what I mean like
literally when you read that serac
camera is it thirty thousand people that
word that were there or it was three
thousand it was a it was a large hug it
was a large host and what was with with
Saul basically everybody that that took
off there they whittled them down to 300
basically and Jonathan goes out there
and he's running ahead of his
armor-bearer
you know as are bears laying people is
he's like go and buy them and God won
this mighty victory for them so you know
like what what Jonathan said is it by
many or by few doesn't matter like God
God's the one in control here and it
doesn't matter we don't need a large
group
we just need willing bodies so that's
the verse what is it that heart and the
harvest is plentiful but the laborers
are a few yeah yeah and I love that
verse because that's what jesus essa'
jesus says and Luke 10:2 right he says
therefore he said unto them the harvest
is truly great but the laborers are few
therefore pray to the lord of the
harvest that he would send forth
laborers into his harvest and I think on
the ministry we're talking about
ministry like everybody has a ministry
and sometimes it's easy to get caught up
when you're in a ministry to think you
know Lord like we need money like we
need we need a building we need you know
camera equipment we need you know
whatever as we start listing all these
things down what we're what we think
we're lacking in and yet that's not what
you just actually asked us to pray for
he actually asked that we pray for
people people and that's crazy because
people the greatest asset right if you
think about some of the greatest movers
and shakers in history have always been
people
you know like saul of tarsus man like he
was out there like totally 180 degrees
against the church right and then
through through Stephen laying down his
life as a witness
he gained a follower of Christ that was
one of the greatest apostles that we've
ever seen no you know so people are
actually the greatest asset and that's
what we should be praying for like
whoever's out there watching you know
like is there a saw is there a is that I
mean is there a paul is there a Gideon
is there a Moses is there a David I mean
these are the individuals that God wants
to yeah and often time like in David's
case the he was the youngest he was the
least likely to be chosen and you know
when when when all of them were walking
in front of Samuel I mean he was like
surely it's this one this one looks good
he's tall he's he's strong he's whatever
and God was like nope nope nope it's the
shepherd boy out there in the field that
I want you know what I mean so so no
matter where you are in your life no
matter what you're doing I mean you you
can even literally support a ministry
with your money that is a form of
ministry I mean we have people that
literally send us donations and things
like this and that's their way of
involving themselves in our ministries
and you as well I mean when you go on
these on these outings
maybe people are like hey look I can't
go but I can you know I give you a
little bit so you can then buy a plane
ticket for someone else to go in my
stead that's a ministry you know what I
mean yeah so there's there's a lot of
ways to get involved that maybe you're
not that type that can actually
physically go there and do that but you
know they're you're still part of a
ministry and like we talked about social
media or whatever I think the Internet
is a great tool to reach the gospel to
the end of the ends of the world I mean
I saw a preach on on TV saying that he
goes to third world countries where
they're living in huts but they all have
phones it said we watch your ministry on
our phone all the time like this is like
this is the time if the gospel is ever
gonna reach the entire world it's now
yep yep so get involved in ministry now
is the time as you can see I mean we're
just we're just three brothers we
actually have one more brother that's
right and
I'll be sitting right next to us you
know we're still we're still working on
him but you know you have a ministry
with your family I mean just to simply
reach out to them like that story you
shared Mike you the testimony of the guy
who was like making videos and his
purpose was really to share it with his
family you know everybody's got a
testimony you may have a testimony of
how God brought you into his fold and
just by simply sharing that with other
people that can be a ministry in and of
itself and encouragement I mean just
encouraging your brethren is a ministry
in itself you know like like like we
talked about earlier if you get have
gratitude it can actually exponentially
change your healing process you can go
to you can go to a convalescent home and
just you know share share the blessings
share that the promises that God has and
you'll watch these old people's worlds
light up you know so get involved in
ministry 2020 time to get focused right
end of the world is right here it's
around the corner and I think when you
get to heaven the thing you're gonna do
is you're gonna look back on your life
and you're gonna say what did I do for
the kingdom of God
what did I do with my time what did I do
with my energies my efforts as you can
see we are all part of very different
types of ministries but you know what if
you start praying God just send me send
me I'll go and then like you said Brock
send me other people that are also
wanting to share in this you'd be
surprised you may have an accountant
someone who just you know all of a
sudden like you know sells houses for a
living I'm just like hey man I want to
edit video for you I don't know you have
no idea
start praying for those people and I
know like our ministry has been blessed
over the years of just random people
coming by and very different skills
Keith who's not here today keith was a
chemist I was like well I don't really
do chemistry but you can work with us
and and he had made some websites and
that's literally how Keith started with
us I came in by making t-shirts that's
right Mike he made t-shirts and stuff
like that so that was some
my dream was like music and making
videos and t-shirts but it was all for
the world and then I was like how am I
gonna use this to glorify God and then I
got too involved in this ministry we
make t-shirts I do video it's like god
bless me with very things that I love
doing yeah that's right and you brought
something to the table which actually
we've all enjoyed have you not now Mike
he's one of our best editors on the tape
on the floor so you know I'm very
excited about you know 2020 where God is
gonna bring this year what we can get
involved in so thanks for watching guys
check out our patreon page if you want
to help support our work and continuous
forward also check out these guys's
websites
Gideon rescue org check out the YouTube
page truth to you youth Castle Valley
Farms Tommy's tonic if you are sick
literally try this product once you will
be a believer and we love that right on
ourselves that's right you can buy it on
our shop little lights Studios TV thank
you for once again for for watching our
videos and a little small ministry you
can share our videos with your friends
and family there can be a ministry right
there for you thanks so much we love you
guys
have a great year this year 2020 we'll
see you next Friday
[Music]